foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is James page here in Madrid at the
ftth conference and I'm joined Now by
Mario Rossetti from open Fiverr Mario
thanks for thanks for coming and talking
to us
um why don't you start by telling us a
bit more about what's been going on at
open fiber uh in the last uh last few
months and years
is the leading wholesale ftth operator
since uh when we start our operation in
2000 back in 2017-18 Italy was lagging
behind in terms of ftth coverage in the
last five years so we have a modern the
coverage of the country that according
to the data that will be released today
it's almost close to 50 percent of the
entire country and we have invested 6
billion uh euros and
we have a 65 penetration rate in the
retail Market the fdth retail Market
okay great so lots of building going on
lots of investment been made but my
understanding is the the the conversion
rate of uh homes in Italy that have the
ability to connect to full fiber uh in
an F from an ftth standpoint and not
necessarily actually taking advantage of
that why is that uh you see in Italy we
have a total 20 million landlines only
3.5 are ftth even if the availability
infrastructure is uh by far larger than
that it only open fiber itself is
already 30 million units covered by ftth
the reason there may there are many
different reasons of the of our markets
but let me just stress too the first one
is that the Italian mobile data market
is one of the cheapest of the world
actually is the second cheapest after
Israel so there are many mobile data
scene that are utilized in instead of a
landline so this is a very relevant
Factor special for summer or houses this
kind of utilization the second point is
that fttc and ftth in Italy have the
same price so there is no real
incentives to for the Telco to switch to
swap the technology from one to the
other because there are no additional
marginality but there are additional
costs that they are incurring in order
to swap from one technology to the other
okay well one of the benefits of the
ftth conference is the fact that it
brings together regulators and operators
so it gives you a chance to to make a
case and to talk about how they might be
able to help that situation what are you
going to be saying to them while you're
here oh we have already made The
Regulators we have already having a
nice discussion about what will be the
next steps in Europe in order to make
feasible and achievable the 2030 Target
of the digital compass so to have the
gigabit Society all around Europe
actually what we will stress is that we
don't need only to put emphasis on the
infrastructure building that is the
where we stand right now but we should
take a step forward also in terms of
utilization of this of this network so
the discussion that we're arriving is
about the possibility for the European
commission that is already taking
consideration this on the draft on the
draft documentation that they send out
on last February is to take in
consideration a progressive switch-off
plan that makes Europe the first
continent to be copper free and a leader
again in terms of digital and green
transformation
absolutely and that's obviously another
key benefit of of ftth is that
sustainability benefits so you see the
the switch off and and the move over
also has some has some green benefits
doesn't it it's a big green benefit so
yesterday uh in a workshop ey presented
the
work a study that was made on a
practical case where the Savings in
terms of energy is over 80 percent uh
when you utilize an fdth Network in
comparison with the old technologists
let's say that is a huge is big is
something that is uh meaningful in terms
of sustainability that's why ftth is
definitely a green technology
fantastic well thank you for coming over
and taking a little while to explain
some of that to us and we hope you have
a great conference thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]